and a sentence was handed down for last
year's mass shooting that was in Buffalo
New York we all remember that one too
the white supremacists who pleaded
guilty to killing 10 black people at a
buffalo grocery store grocery store
rather was sentenced to life in prison
after a very emotional and heated court
hearing as Jeff Begay shows us three
surviving victims and relatives of the
people who died that day told the
convicted killer exactly what they
thought of him
you are a cowardly racist
one by one I watched you kill my mom
family members are those killed inside a
buffalo grocery store last May address
the gunman
you came into the biggest part the
strongest part of the black community
and you ripped us apart
delivering emotional statements about
relatives killed in the attack fueled by
the 19 year old white supremacists who
prosecutors argued wanted to start a
race war
Barbara Maps 72 year old sister
Catherine Massey was shot and killed
there's nothing Kevin wouldn't do for
people I will personally to choke you
and leave my fingerprints on your neck
as Maps turn from the podium during her
Victim Impact statement her son charged
the gunman
deputies jumped in
and rushed the shooter out of the
courtroom while the judge attempted to
defuse the tension in November the
shooter pleaded guilty to the most
serious State charges against him
including first-degree murder and
domestic terrorism there can be no mercy
for you
no understanding
no Second Chances New York law requires
a mandatory life sentence I'm very sorry
for all the pain I forced the victims
and their families to suffer through
that apology did not sit well with the
family of Catherine Massey what did you
think when he apologized it means
nothing to us you can't bring cat back
he did what he came to do
I call him an instrument of evil I'm
angry yeah I hate him but I don't hate
him I wish I didn't get a hold to him
I would like to talk to him and I'd like
to teach them a couple things and then I
like to kick his ass do you think he
deserves the death penalty 100 you need
to go
the gunman has a federal court hearing
today he faces dozens of federal charges
that he has pleaded not guilty to Nate
Jeff thank you we appreciate you